- Ces logement ne sont peut-être
pas très grands...
(en anglais)
- ... Mais pour Zuri-Kinshasa
Maria Terry, qui vivait
dans la rue, c'est un espace où
elle se sent enfin à la maison
et en sécurité.
ZURI-KINSHASA MARIA TERRY,
résidente d'une mini-maison
(en anglais)
"Je peine à y croire",
dit-elle, "je me réveille
dans un endroit et peu importe
la taille, j'ai de l'intimité."
C'est qu'en plus de contenir
deux lits et d'être climatisées
et chauffées, ces maisons
de six mètres carrés
se verrouillent de l'intérieur
et de l'extérieur.
JÉRÔME BESTUL
personne sans-abri
(en anglais)
"Vous n'avez pas à vous
inquiéter que des gens entrent
par effraction et prennent
vos effets personnels."
Trois autres villages sont
installés sur des terrains
vagues d'anciens stationnements
à Los Angeles.
ROWAN VANSLEVE, dir. fin.
ONG Hope of the Valley
(en anglais)
- La ville a acheté 466 petites
maisons préfabriquées. Elles
coûtent entre 5000 et 9000 $ US,
et s'assemblent en 90 minutes.
C'est l'organisme
Home of the Valley qui s'occupe
de la gestion des sites.
Il ne s'agit pas que d'offrir
un toit aux persones sans abri,
mais aussi un véritable filet
social.
ROWAN VANSLEVE, dir. fin.
ONG Hope of the Valley
(en anglais)
"Et tous ces services, qu'ils
s'agissent de santé mentale,
de soins médicaux,
d'accompagnement pour
dépendance, nous poursuivrons
avec eux quand ils trouveront
un logement permanent.
- Ces villages se veulent
une solution temporaire,
une transition entre la rue
et une maison permanente.
Zuri-Kinshasa Maria Terry compte
bien saisir cette chance à deux
mains pour repartir à zéro.
(anglais)
Ici Alexie André-Bélisle,
Radio-Canada, M